hi in this video we will talk about
follicular dendritic cells the
follicular dendritic cells are generally
found in primary and secondary lymphoid
follicles of our lymph node or the
spleen and they are very different from
the dendritic cell that we know has an
antigen presenter now though the name
suggests follicular dendritic cell they
are not at all similar to the dendritic
cell because they are not antigen
presenting cells that they are not
phagocytic and they don't have class 2
MHC molecule which is the hallmark
signature of an antigen presenting cell
other than that every C's are somehow
molecularly are morphologically similar
to the dendritic cell but in terms of
molecular identity and developmental
origin they are very different from a
dendritic cell but key role of
follicular dendritic cell is to present
oxidized antigen to a b-cell present in
the follicle and in this video we are
going to talk about development of
follicular dendritic cell function of
follicular dendritic cell they are
subcellular localization and the
molecular signatures which are unique to
follicular dendritic cell and not
present in dendritic cell so let's begin
and please watch this video to the end
and if you like this video give it a big
thumbs up and don't forget subscribe now
we're talking about follicular dendritic
cell and if we compare to the dendritic
cell they are very distinct now
morphologically they have similarities
both of them has processes which are
dendrite like it looks like these
processes would be used to capture
antigens but it's wrong in case of
molecule a dendritic cell they don't
capture antigen they don't have
parasitic nature they don't even display
antigens on class 2 MHC molecules so
where do they come from the normal
dendritic cell they come from the bone
marrows hematopoietic we will pretend
steps in the myeloid progenitor or the
lymphoid proteins or both can give rise
to
dendritic cell but turns our
the follicular dendritic cell are not
derived from the bone marrow precursors
it is predicted that they are derived
from mesenchymal progenitors though the
exact origin is still not known and
active research is going on to delineate
that question now empty seats can be
found in spleen and lymph node and to
some extent they can also be found in
the mucous associated lymphoid tissues
let's zoom in to a lymph node to
understand where these follicular
dendritic cells are present the follicle
until it excels as you can see they are
present in the follicles which is the B
cell area where we can find the P cells
now for we can you send cell dendritic
cells are not present in the t-cell area
now inside the follicle follicles what
they do is form elaborate networks and
these networks are very important to
support the proliferation of the
activated b-cell so the clonal expansion
is heavily augmented by these kind of
follicular dendritic cells in mice were
follicular dendritic cells are depleted
in that nice clonal expansion is
abrogated now the follicular dendritic
cell also present optimized antigen that
means the antigen which is already bound
to antibodies follicular dendritic cell
expressed CR receptors and also FC
receptors the FC receptors can bind to
the FC region of the oxidized antigen
and in that format they can present it
on to the b-cells
so b-cell use or utilize the follicular
dendritic cell as a platform to serve a
antigens and that's a key function of
the follicular dendritic cell it serves
as a platform where b-cells can choose
their antigens now coming to the
molecular features follicular dendritic
cell expresses FC receptors which is
very important for them because they
need to display the oxidized antigen to
the b-cells
now they have CR 1 and CR 2 receptors
these are complement receptors which are
very important for them other than that
some unique receptors known as
FDC m1 and M
you are unique to the follicular
dendritic cell phonee killer dendritic
cells do not Express class 2 MHC class 2
MHC is present in all kind of antigen
presenting cells such as the dendritic
cell but the follicular dendritic cell
even if they are little bit similar in
terms of morphology they don't have
class 2 MHC expression and we talked
about their unique marker expression as
well right now let's talk about their
functions among the key functions that
they play is to organize the follicular
marek microarchitecture now they
actually help to form the germinal
Center inside this b-cell follicular
Aliens other important function is to
attract the B cells because follicular
dendritic cell can secret chemokines
such as CX CL 13 which is received by
the killing chemokine receptor ccr5 and
that is how these particular b-cells get
attracted to this follicular dendritic
cell and this would induce them to
sample more antigens and get activated
that is a key function of follicular
dendritic cells so in this video we
pretty much talked about the origin
development function of the follicular
dendritic cell and their unique
molecular signatures so I hope you
enjoyed this video if you like this
video we will become something forget to
like share and subscribe thank you